I'm Florio Stooges Monday the director  for Rihanna's new video sledgehammer  sledgehammer is about breaking down  walls it's a standalone piece with  really strong ties to Star Trek beyond  this is the first music video you'll see  in my Maps Star Trek and Rihanna with  IMAX the quality that you're gonna see  is going to be incredible the idea of  taking it somewhere that had this  otherworldly landscape and using  elements from the film like the swarm  ships and floating rocks were a perfect  combination it's her own character that  she embodies and becomes like powerful  they love Star Trek's been a part of me  since my childhood this song is about  being stuck and finding the strength to  get past that  it needed to be impactful very emotional  dramatic and haunting at the same time  the film and the song fit beautifully  together  I think people be surprised with her  transformation keep it going keep it  going  beautiful  thank you guys